I was sort of like following the track
many people were having these kinds of
experiences at just that time but then
in Jay in February of 1967 I sort of
found my way at the front of the parade
of when one rainy evening in Berkeley
this friend of mine who I'm still
extremely tight with and this guy always
was first in everything and you know he
made it his business to burn through and
abandon things before you'd ever heard
of them and he arrived at my house this
rainy February night and he said I have
something I want you to try I said what
is it he said it's a new psychedelic and
I said how long does it last
and he said three minutes and I said no
problem you know we're acid heads we can
handle three minutes of anything and sat
down and smoked my first DMT and you
know it's never been the same sense I
mean it worked a hundred percent yes
this was the famous 55-gallon drum that
was boosted off a army conveyance
vehicle when it was moved from SR I to
some proving ground in the southwest the
US Army was trying to develop an aerosol
artillery shell that would land in a
Vietnamese village drive everyone nuts
and you could send your people in and
take over in all this gaseous
hallucinogenic confusion and diem
he and even been more debilitating
psychedelics were being looked at in the
service of this and it's a famous story
in the underground that there was this
one 55-gallon drum of pure crystalline
material that somebody just made sure
fell into a ditch in Menlo Park
somewhere and somebody else came along
five minutes later and picked it up and
rumor persists that that 55-gallon drum
is not empty yet apocryphal stories
abound of burial sites near Hudson's Bay
in the deserts of the Namib other places
it's been moved around even the Dome of
the rock was indicated it at one time so
I don't suggest you go looking for it
under the Dome of the rock